gear 5 has broken the anime World twice
now and even though it's already one of
the most iconic transformations in anime
history there are still a ton of
unanswered questions and Mysteries
surrounding these incredible powers and
so today we're going to discuss
everything that we know about gear 5 and
Luffy's mythical sun god Nika's own
devil fruit starting with how Luffy
actually awakened this Legendary Power
in the first place and wow let me tell
you it seems like unlocked it by
straight up dying because in episode
1070 kaido absolutely crushes Luffy in
our stride Captain is apparently dead
for a moment here and while this part
isn't exactly clear kaido sure seems to
think that Luffy has died for good this
time and heads down on a rampage inside
the castle honestly stuff like that
always blows my mind just how creative
and Powerful one piece really is and you
can now bring this awesomeness to your
browser as well using today's sponsor
Opera GX I'm in love with their video
player not only has it this super
convenient pop-out feature but you can
now actually transfer the video you are
watching right now from one device to
another if you're Frankie you can
monitor and limit your RAM and CPU usage
I was really surprised when they
recently added the option to custom mod
the entire browser itself for example
picking a mod like this one here to
customize really much everything
background music keyboard sound tap
sounds dedicated wallpapers themes
colors and you can even disable and
enable individual mods in the mods menu
from the sidebar including by the way
some fantastic fan made one or you can
go set your own custom animated
wallpapers as well like this one from
Spirited Away and using Opera's quick
tool you can import everything from your
previous browser in less than a minute
for your own personal time skip here and
to top it all off if you download Opera
for free using my link you will get an
exclusive feature in your GX corner
where you'll be able to see my 12 latest
uploaded videos including this one which
will continue right now even momonosuke
claims that Luffy's voice is quote
unquote gone and since Momo has the
voice of all things we should be fairly
confident that Momo isn't making things
up right here although there is another
explanation for this that we'll discuss
in just a moment because right after we
get this legendary smile and with this
Joy boy has returned which actually
means that Luffy has awakened his devil
fruit and unlocked the true powers of
that devil fruit plus quite conveniently
I'd say the five Elder Stars explained
to us in that moment that Luffy's devil
fruit is really not the gomugomonomi but
it is instead the mythical Zone human
human fruit model Sun Gods Nika and so
before we get into all the crazy changes
that this will make to the story later
on let's explain first what these Powers
appear to allow Luffy to do in the first
place first of all the Elder stars go on
to explain that the first ability of
this fruit is to turn the user's body
into rubber so that part is pretty
consistent with what we thought about
Luffy's devil fruit all along in the
first place but that is of course only
the beginning because we are then told
that when fighting the user is
supposedly only limited by their
imagination which is the most
interesting part of course about Luffy's
new power up and that's because Luffy
then reaches down into the castle with
an enormous Fist and grabs the giant
dragon kaido like he is a child playing
with some sort of snake toy and then we
truly get to see these wild powers in
action because Luffy puffs up his
muscles like a cartoon character swings
kaido around like a tornado and slams
him back and forth as if kaido was light
in a feather in other words clearly
Luffy has gained an incredible power who
since he's able to casually beat down
kaido and Emperor like we've never seen
before in the story which of course
brings us to his next Super broken
ability which is actually something that
is normal for paramecia devil fruit
Awakenings that's because we also see
luffia literally grab the rooftop and
bend it up to block kaido's blast breath
and so basically what he's doing here is
turning his environment into rubber
which we've seen many times before with
awakened paramecia devil fruits like
doflamingo strings or katakuri's Mochi
however something even more unique about
Luffy's awakened Powers is that he can
also seemingly turn other people into
rubber as well we do see this later when
he blows up kaido like a balloon
stretches through kaido's eyeballs and
body plus even more stuff and so his
Awakening clearly allows him to turn
both the environment but also other
living people and beings into rubber at
the least when he's touching them but
perhaps the most broken of Luffy's
abilities and the one that most people
think of with gear 5 is Luffy's new
found ability to make his imagination
into reality let me repeat that he can
turn his imagination into reality and
this is where the devil fruit truly
becomes one of the most overpowered
abilities in the series because as we've
already seen Luffy can now do things
that just seem absolutely impossible
such as freely manipulating his size to
become bigger and buffer even giant size
and we will even see later on that he
can apparently create things out of thin
air like goggles but that's just a start
because Luffy's new powers might also
explain one of the biggest mysteries
about his powers ever since the time
skip that's because back in Fishman
Island Luffy first revealed that he
somehow had fire powers when he defeated
this Fishman here with his red hog
attack and then as you'll remember just
a while ago against kaido he used an
even bigger Red Rock fire attack which
just completely blew my mind in the
anime by the way and for years many
people have been theorizing that Luffy
could use fire because of super hot
friction but now we finally know for
sure that his fire abilities most likely
have just been an early example of
Luffy's extraordinary devil fruit
Awakening and basically him imagining
his brother's powers and honestly that
might just be the start of Luffy's
Elemental abilities because little
spoiler warning here gear 5 has even
allowed Luffy to grab lightning and
throw it at his opponent so in the
future he might even be able to
manipulate other elements or even devil
fruit abilities with his absurdly
powerful new abilities however there are
some very important and severe drawbacks
and limitations to this ability that we
simply have to discuss as well including
one that might actually change Luffy
forever but first even though it's
explained that Luffy is only limited by
his imagination basically it is
definitely not an unlimited power for
example he cannot just quote unquote
imagine that kaido is defeated and it
will automatically happen so it isn't an
instant win wish for anything kind of
condition also the gear 5 power seem
mostly contained to Luffy's body or
things that he seems to be touching so
he cannot just snap his fingers and
change the world at least not yet which
actually brings us to the very crucial
fact that much like Luffy's earlier gear
Transformations gear second third or
fourth when Luffy uses his awakened
Powers it does seem to dramatically
drain his stamina and possibly even his
lifespan in fact we even see him comment
that he only has a few minutes to use
this power and also witness a terrifying
transformation into an old man during a
break in the fighting but all of this is
nothing compared to one other potential
danger of Luffy's Awakening because
remember when we said that Luffy seemed
to die before he awakened his powers
well one theory about Luffy's Awakening
is that he actually did die and then the
spirit of his devil fruit somehow took
over Luffy's body and there's actually
some real evidence supporting this such
as Luffy's heartbeat clearly changing
and his uncontrollable laughter while
using this new Fork I mean even the
giant elephant sunicia comments that
this is the first time that they have
heard Luffy's unique sounding heartbeat
in over 800 years and then they even
make it absolutely clear that Joy boy
their old comrades has once and for all
returned so while this hasn't been
clearly explained even in the manga at
this point it is possible that by dying
Luffy somehow allowed the spirit of Joy
boy to literally enter his body and
bring Luffy back to life yeah that'll
sound weird but we do have
consider that devil fruits do seem to
seem to unwill of their own so the
spirit of Joy boy may have been living
inside the devil food for all these
hundreds of years just waiting for the
right person to finally awaken these
abilities now you may be asking why is
this supposed to be dangerous for Luffy
well when we first see this
transformation it is a little bit scary
to see Luffy laughing maniacally like
this right here and it does seem that he
literally cannot stop laughing so we
have to at least consider the idea that
Luffy's Awakening has led some ancient
Spirit come in and alter his personality
here which might very well be the reason
why Momo felt that Luffy's voice
disappeared because it is possible that
his voice just completely changed once
he unlocked gear 5. and while this might
sound unlikely who really knows what
could be possible with these new
abilities although one thing that we
have been shown throughout the entire
series is that whenever Luffy unlocks a
new ability such as gear second third or
fourth at first at least Luffy has some
very serious drawbacks like a time limit
or turning into a chibi Luffy but
eventually he then Masters the new power
and can use it without much limitation
and so maybe maybe the same will happen
for gear 5 in the future as well which
could lead to an even more powerful
Luffy in the future even though this is
likely his last major gear upgrade for
now but before we get into
saying foreshadowing and future
importance of gear 5 for the story and
the anime let's discuss for a moment
here the history of this actual devil
fruit because we knew all the way back
at the start of the story that Shanks
and his crew stole this legendary devil
fruit from a world government ship and
so the world government did have it at
some point which always made me wonder
why they had it in the first place well
thankfully we've recently had some more
context about this from who's who who
was one of the cp9 agents on that ship
and since this was cp9 with the devil
fruit it does make me believe that they
were sent on a specific mission to find
and retrieve this devil fruit and so it
seems like the world government has been
hunting this fruit which was actually
100 confirmed in this episode when the
Elder Stars tell us that the world
government has been trying and failing
to acquire this fruit for 800 years wow
imagine searching for anything for that
long having finally found it and then
losing it when some pirate steal it from
your ship however then we also have to
ask ourselves why they wanted it so
badly but I think we can clearly see the
answer to that question in this episode
not only is it simply an insane power
strengthwise that apparently hasn't been
awoken ever since the void Century but
the government must also be worried
about some secret abilities that we
still don't know about and honestly it
could very well be related to the one
piece itself we'll discuss more about
that in a moment but the government were
so scared of someone unlocking its true
powers that they even changed the devil
fruits official name to the gomugomonomi
to keep people away from it but now that
Luffy has awakened it we're going to see
exactly why they have been trying to
claim it and keep it secret for all
these years however not everybody seemed
to be as thrilled with Luffy's new
powers especially the reveal that we had
his devil fruit wrong all this time for
over 20 years and while admittedly it
isn't the most clearly foreshadow twist
in one piece there are absolute scenes
throughout the story that we can point
to that might have very well hinted at
these legendary powers and of course it
all begins with the very first image
that we have of the newly awakened Joy
boy and if you're thinking that this
image looks familiar well that would be
because we've seen a very similar pose
multiple times in the story for example
it shows up twice in both of the bonfire
scenes on Sky Pia so clearly this post
was already established way back in the
story and this is even more important
when you consider the context of this
guy Pia Arc really the entire point of
this adventure was to free this guy Pian
people from the false god Eno and how
does Luffy do this well ultimately he
wins the final Clash by breaking up the
dark clouds to allow the sun to shine
down on the praying people below and now
if that isn't super important for
shadowing for Luffy being the literal
Sun Gods then I do not know what is
besides the concept of the Dawn is a
huge symbolic device in all of One Piece
and Luffy's victories are often
paralleled with the sun literally Rising
like on Thriller bark or a dark period
on an Island's history finally ending
like on Alabaster or dress Rosa plus
we've already mentioned Luffy's
firepowers being possible because of
gear 5 but there have also been other
examples of very strange abilities that
may have foreshadowed that his powers
were more than simple rubber for example
Luffy's crazy attack calvaryn allows him
to bend his robber multiple times
mid-air now many opponents such as
doflamingo and even kaido have remarked
that rubber simply shouldn't be able to
do this but now it was likely because of
Luffy's true Awakening all along gear 4
being a kind of pre-step to that but
really that's not the only bit of
foreshadowing for this ridiculous power
up because in fact way back during the
imple down Arc Luffy is talking to these
random prisoners and they even go as far
as to say that he must be sent here by
Destiny which makes way more sense later
on when we get to see the very first
mention of sangod Nika in episode 1000
40 during gymbase fight against who's
who that's because this former member of
cp9 was once imprisoned in impo down and
it was during his time in that prison
that he learned from other prisoners
that they sometimes pray to the sun god
Nika who would supposedly free the
prisoners and slaves which just adds so
much needed context to this scene with
Luffy talking to these prisoners here
which now of course brings us to the
real purpose of Luffy's Awakening and
the true nature of his devil fruit now
we've already discussed that the sun god
Nika is a legendary figure who freed the
slaves and it's very likely that this
figure was also the original Joy boy
from the void Century since sunisha told
us that joyboy had returned right when
Luffy awakened his fruit and honestly I
personally don't really think that Luffy
is literally the old Joy boy
reincarnated instead it's much more
likely that Luffy has simply inherited
his will and will continue to carry out
the task that the old Joy boy never
managed to complete and so we of course
have to ask what exactly is that task
and that promised that he never meant to
keep well it's the exact same thing that
Luffy has been doing all throughout the
story freeing islands and liberating
oppressed people in fact the only thing
that we know for a fact that the old Joy
boy truly wanted to do was a promise
that he left on a pony glyph on Fishman
islands and while we don't know for 100
sure we can very much assume that this
promise was to bring the fishermen up to
the surface where they could live in
peace and so if Luffy is going to
complete the task that was unfinished by
the previous Joy boy it will very likely
involve liberating the world and all of
the oppressed races such as the fishmen
the Mings the dwarves and many many
other people in fact Luffy's return as
joyboy may have even been left in a
prophecy along with the legendary
treasure on love tale and that's because
when Roger finally found the one piece
all he and his men could do was laugh at
what they had found the former pirating
even states that he wished he could have
lived in the time of Joy boy and he also
knew that the one-piece treasure somehow
couldn't be used and until 20 years into
the future but now that Luffy has
finally awakened we assume that the
prophesized time has finally come and
Luffy will be able to use whatever the
first Joy boy actually left behind on
love tale which will ultimately result
in a final battle against either the
darkness fruit user Blackbeard or the
secret ruler of the world government emu
by the way Luffy's gear 5 transformation
funnily enough is completely white which
is the exact opposite of Blackbeard's
Darkness as well as emu's black outfit
that we always see them wearing and of
course we have to assume because of the
Epic powers of this devil fruit that
Luffy will surely come out on top of
this final world-changing clash and save
the world which is exactly why the Nika
fruit made it into my top 5 most
overpowered devil fruits in one piece
and if you want to know which fruits are
even more powerful than this one you can
watch that video right here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one